(explosion)
- Aux portes de l'Ukraine,
la Russie a plployé
2500 soldats de plus.
Des bruits de bottes qui
résonnent de plus en plus fort
dans l'est du pays : une autre
provocation de la Russie
à 50 kilomètres des frontières.
Et une présumée incursion dans
les serveurs de l'administration
publique ukrainienne.
"Une cyberattaque a été commise
contre certains sites web
gouvernementaux, explique
ce porte-parole, sans qu'aucune
fuite de données ne se soit
produite", assure-t-il.
Le régime de Vladimir Poutine
semble déterminé à maintenir
la pression sur l'Ukraine,
mais aussi sur les États-Unis,
l'Europe et leurs alliés
de l'OTAN.
Mais ce n'est pas tout.
Ces manoeuvres pourraient mener
à une escalade encore
plus grave.
Un scénario de déstabilisation
dont le Kremlin a le secret
pour justifier sesemememements.
"Nous avons assisté à ça avant,
en 2014", affirme la porte-
parole de la Maison-Blanche,
en référence à l'annexion de la
Crim l l l la Russie. "Des actes
de sabotage visant à accuser
l'Ukraine de préparer
une attaque imminente
contre les forces russes
dastststst du pays."
Après une semaine de
pourparlers infructueux avec les
États-Unis et l'OTAN, la Russie
semble déterminée à poursuivre
sa politique agressive
envers l'Ukraine.
"Notre patience est à bout",
affirme le ministre des Affaires
étrangères russes, qui accuse
l'Occident de ne pas tenir
ses promesses de non-expansion
de l'OTAN vers l'Est.
Des promesses orales
que James Baker aurait faites
à Mikhail Gorbatchev en 1990.
Mais pour cet expert, l'Ukraine
est bien plus qu'un simple
territoire à conquérir.
DOMINIQUE AREL, Chaire d'études
ukrainiennes Université d'Ottawa
- Ce que nous dit Poutine, c'est
que l'Ukraine est une partie
intégrale de l'identité russe,
alors il ne peut pas y avoir
de compromis. En mettant ce type
de pression-là, on teste
l'Occident. Puis, évidemment, on
met de la pression sur l'Ukraine
en créant ce climat,
qui laisse à croire
qu'une guerre est imminente.
- Les États-Unis et leurs alliés
ont pourtant été très clairs :
toute agression envers l'Ukraine
sera suivie d'une riposte,
à tout le moins économique,
contre Moscou.
Ici Yasmine Khayat,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
Des développements
qui surviennent à la fin
d'une semaine de discussions
intensives entre Moscou
et l'Occident. On en parle avec
notre correspondante en Russie.
Donc, Tamara, force est de
constater qu'elles n'ont pas
mené à grand-chose,
ces discussions.
TAMARA ALTERESCO
- Il n'y a pas grande marge
de manoeuvre. J'étais à la
conférence de Serguei Lavrov
aujourd'hui, à Moscou.
Elle a duré trois heures, et
presque toutes les questions ont
porté sur cette confrontation
avec l'Occident. Et il a répété
très clairement, trois fois
plutôt qu'une : la patience
de la Russie s'amenuise.
Il a dit : "On veut une réponse
écrite et détaillée des États-
Unis au sujet de nos demandes."
Et ces demandes, elles sont
claires, elles sont nettes,
elles sont précises, et surtout,
non négociables. La Russie veut
que l'OTAN cesse son expansion,
s'engage à ne jamais admettre
l'Ukraine au sein de ses rangs
et elle veut le retrait
des troupes de l'OTAN des pays
qui avoisinent la Russie.
La suite, il l'a dit
très clairement, dépend des
États-Unis. Donc, ça ressemble
drôlement à un ultimatum
dans la mesure où on sait déjà
que l'OTAN et les États-Unis
ont dit : Non, c'est hors
de question. On n'ira pas là.
Donc, on a le droit,
aujourd'hui, je vous dirais,
de craindre le pire, même si
on peut encore l'éviter,
une action militaire, et ça,
la Russie ne s'en cache pas.
Elle a plus de 100 000 soldats
déployés un peu partout
aux frontières de l'Ukraine,
et la Russie étudie ses options.
- Les États-Unis, de leur côté,
veulent poursuivre
les pourparlers. Est-ce encore
possible à ce stade-ci?
- Moscou ne voit pas l'utilité
de poursuivre les pourparlers
dans les circonstances
actuelles. Le terrain n'est pas
assez fertile, donc ça cause
beaucoup cette instabilité
politique de remous sur les
marchés ici. Le rouble,
depuis jeudi, a perdu du poil.
Au pire, c'était 3 % de sa
valeur face au dollar américain.
C'est sans compter qu'à
Washington, on prépare au Sénat
un projet de loi avec des
sanctions extraordinaires
qui attaquerait non seulement
les banques russes, mais
l'entourage de monsieur Poutine
et le président lui-même.
Ça aussi, ça aide pas, disons,
à l'atmosphère et aux
négociations. Donc, on nage
vraiment dans des eaux troubles
avec une Russie qui veut,
aujourd'hui, réclame un nouveau
pacte de sécurité en Europe pour
réparer ce qu'elle considère
les erreurs du passé,
la trahison de l'Ouest,
et de l'autre côté, l'OTAN qui
refuse de faire des concessions.
Et monsieur Lavrov,
encore une fois, a été très
clair en conférence de presse
aujourd'hui. Il a dit :
"Les concessions, on en a assez
fait. La balle est dans le camp
des États-Unis. On croit
qu'avec la bonne volonté,
il y a moyen de s'entendre,
mais on se prépare
pour toute éventualité."
- Merci beaucoup, Tamara,
à Moscou.
- Au revoir.